close
encounters of the third kind is just one
of the countless films that imagines
mankind's first
contact with an alien civilization now a
harvard astronomer thinks it's actually
happened
in his new book extraterrestrial the
first sign of intelligent life beyond
earth
avi loeb says we may have had a brush
with an
alien civilization less than four years
ago i was not a fan of science fiction
because
the storyline often violates the laws of
physics really
i never liked star trek for example so
no star trek no e.t no
no no no i just follow the evidence you
see like sherlock holmes like a
detective
in this talk i would like to venture
professor avi loeb
is a respected astrophysicist former
chair of harvard's astronomy department
and a published author this boils down
to the fundamental question
are we alone so when he delivered his
hypothesis in 2018
now a best-selling book extraterrestrial
some eyebrows were raised do you believe
we have been how should i say this
had a close encounter of some kind
yeah well there was this object
discovered in 2017.
on october 19th of that year hawaii's
powerful pan stars telescope
spotted a mysterious object whizzing by
it was traveling so fast at nearly 200
000 miles an hour
astronomers concluded it must have
originated from outside our solar system
the first such interstellar traveler
ever detected
it was given the name amuamua the
hawaiian word
for scout about the size of a football
field most scientists believed it was
just an oddly shaped asteroid or comet
but not loeb there is some evidence that
looks
unexplainable except the most plausible
solution
seems to me that it's artificially made
i spoke with him at the harvard
smithsonian center for astrophysics in
cambridge massachusetts
in the school's 174 year old observatory
at first astronomers told oh it's just a
rock
it's just the uh economics yeah
but there was no cometary tail around it
no gas
coming off it and so it was not a comet
for sure
then there was the shape of the object
it's been rendered in
illustrations as long and narrow like a
cigar
but loeb and a few other scientists say
it was actually flat
possibly less than a millimeter thick
and
highly reflective much like a light sail
and it actually sped up and changed its
expected trajectory
as it sling shotted around the sun it
was
because of reflection of sunlight just
like when you have a sail on a boat
and it reflects the wind it gets pushed
it turns out that in september 2020
there was another object that exhibited
an extra push away from the sun
and didn't have a cometary tail turns
out
it was a rocket booster from 1966 that
was
launched and we can tell that it's
hollow and
thin because we produced it the question
is who produced
this object from 2017. so
you see this as intelligent life yes you
feel as though
umuah is a relic of some past
technological advance from some past
civilization and it may be space trash
you know it may be something that is not
functional anymore
we sent out voyager 1 voyager 2 new
horizons
these are probes that were operational
when we communicated with them
but they're gone a billion years from
now there will be junk there will be
just equipment floating in space
you spend a lot of time up here every
now and then
of course life wasn't always about
trying to prove the existence of alien
life for this professor loeb grew up on
a small
family farm in israel about 15 miles
south of tel aviv
and unlike many other children of the
60s he didn't dream of becoming an
astronaut
he had no interest in astronomy or
science fiction
no no i was interested in philosophy the
most fundamental questions
i grew up on a farm collected eggs every
afternoon
and used to drive a tractor to the hills
and read philosophy books but that
offered me an advantage because i look
at everything that astronomers do
as an outsider from outside with a big
picture in mind
that outsider's point of view helps loeb
deal with the mostly
negative reactions he's getting from his
own colleagues
in science and academia what is the
scientific community's reaction
well there is a lot of pushback
seems to have been nothing more than a
shard of rock
one of those colleagues is time magazine
science editor-at-large
jeffrey kluger among all of the possible
solutions or explanations
for the fact that this rock is
accelerating
the least likely of them all is that
there's a natural intelligence aboard
that's doing the driving
but loeb isn't concerning himself too
much with his naysayers
the point is i follow what basketball
coaches tell their team members keep
your eyes on the ball
not on the audience so i don't care how
many likes i have on twitter
i follow what nature tells us
the public wants to know are we alone i
get enormous extraordinary attention to
the book
and i say if the public is interested in
the public funds science
isn't it the obligation of scientists to
discuss this topic and research it
mua has long left our solar system but
lowe believes
more objects like it will eventually be
discovered
for now his search for alien life in the
cosmos
continues you i presume
if you're patient enough plan to be
proven right
oh yeah it all depends whether we keep
our eyes open
and search for these things because if
you are not
willing to search you will never find
wonderful things
[Music]
and aside from his contention that this
brief visitor to our solar system was of
alien origin
here's the big question do you believe
in ufos
well frankly i don't think we deserve
the attention of
alien civilizations we are not
particularly intelligent
if you read the news every day we are
doing terrible things so your answer is
no
probably not my
wife says if a spaceship ever lands in
our backyard
and calls me in i should make sure that
i do two things
one leave the car keys with her
you're not coming back and two
make sure that they don't ruin the loan
when they lift off
so she's okay with them taking you just
told me that's for you to interpret
[Laughter]
pete was he was so much fun to talk to
delightful
yeah i i this this notion of just how
vast space is and then how old it is
and that this could be a relic from some
past civilization it just kind of just
blew my mind
and opened me up to so much more
essentially he's like
would mark be okay if you just took off
on
we wouldn't be okay